new york jets 0-3 and they have not
looked good chris the last couple of
weeks and it's raised questions about
the job security of adam gase in his
second season with the team
there was a suggestion earlier this week
from colin coward that if they lose
tonight gases out coward was basing that
on
a report which the jets have since
refuted who knows what the truth is but
the report is that christopher johnson
the ceo of the jets has been calling
around to agents to line up candidates
to coach the team well that doesn't mean
that they're going to hire from the
outside
on an interim basis nobody does that it
would be greg williams most likely
running the show for the rest of the
year this is about next year that
doesn't mean you're going to fire gays
now now i if they get embarrassed by the
broncos
in prime time that could be an issue
yeah that could be an issue there's a
report from nfl media that gates is not
going to be fired if the
jets should lose at home tonight to the
broncos but i i you know here's here's
my
my balancing act on this
adam gay stepped into a bad
dysfunctional situation that's going to
take some time to fix and it's a
multi-year rebuild but at the same time
you can't just give up you can't have a
team that that doesn't seem like it's
capable of even being remotely
competitive in any game it plays
that's the problem you can't just mail
it in until the rebuild is complete
you've still got to find a way to live
in the house while you're rebuilding
that's right yeah that's right you know
there's no sizzle to the team right
there's nothing that like can like get
the jets fans to gravitate towards them
and just go oh wait i feel good about
this i see the vision of where we're
going here that's the problem and i mean
you're right too crap
crap was left to adam gase when he took
over there i mean that was crap so
but
i i can't disagree right now the way
it's trending it's almost seems
inevitable
and if they lost to this broncos team
tonight bad like listen i think anything
would be on the table i do because the
broncos i mean they're starting a third
string quarterback they're banged up
football team across the board that
would be a bad look i mean if they
somehow lost by like 10 points or
something like that
uh i would be worried if i'm adam gase
the next day but i mean i think that's
the big thing too though i just you know
again what was set up there for him
beforehand is so bad it's hard to have
any sizzle at all because there's
nothing
on the roster that can even like
remotely say
oh they're not taking advantage of the
full sizzle factor of what that guy can
do there's nobody there that do that
they're not missing out on anybody
the previous gm
took christian hackenberg in the second
round he was an undraftable quarterback
it was the worst second round pick in
the history of football i could throw
better with my other arm and they
drafted a quarterback in the second
round that just tells you where the
state of this franchise is right now and
i don't know where to say it
sorry
you said you've said plenty um but but
you're right look they were trying to
build from the outside in not the inside
out joe douglas is trying to build from
the inside out the the question is will
adam gase end up on the outside looking
in if they just can't
do something positive during this period
of time where they're trying to get the
players necessary to make the jets into
a contending team all right let's get
through some of the
props for the thursday night game uh
provided by our partners at points bet
sportsbook let's begin with a simple one
more passing yards brett not mark ripon
or sam darnold yeah i mean i'm going to
go with sam darnold but i'm not
confident about it i'm not i mean i mean
brett ripon has better weapons at his
disposal it's not even close it's not
even close the jets wide receivers are
really challenged and getting open i
know that that i mean it's look at the
group without jameson crowder it's a
bunch of journeymen who can't get on a
team for more than two or three years at
a time or guys that are really old and
at the end of their career so
i'm gonna go with sam darnold just
because it's sam darnold and i'm gonna
give him the respect and i don't know
what to expect from brett ripman and the
other thing is greg williams is creative
uh and and denver defense is beat up so
just because of that i'll go with sam
darnold but i don't like feel cozy as
you should with sam darnold versus brett
rippon
yeah it should be
third overall pick in the 2018 draft
versus an undrafted guy from 2019 it's a
no-brainer right and and i'm gonna go
donald in part two because who knows
maybe it's gonna be a revolving door i
think vic fangio the coach of the team
left open the possibility of maybe some
jeff driscoll being sprinkled in from
time to time or maybe just brett rippon
gets benched right like driscoll got
benched last week all right uh
frank gore over under 54.5 rushing yards
what do you got uh i i'm gonna go over
just because
the only thing that scares me is he just
doesn't get enough carries but i but
like if he's in there enough i'm gonna
say over because the denver broncos d
line is just jarrell casey demarcus
walker somebody else i'm missing von
miller of course but there's some
another defensive tackle that i can't
call in my brain right now with recall
that's out to where i just look at that
and then the jets also got to realize
that they're throwing challenged as is
that they need to rely on their running
game a little bit so i'll go with gore
on the over
yeah i agree with you as well and look i
just think that the jets are finally
getting
uh the benefit of playing a team that's
that's not very good and the broncos
aren't very good right now because of
all the injuries
most receiving yards jerry judy the
broncos rookie or the field
i'm gonna go with the field i mean jerry
judy is definitely gonna be in the
conversation for the best wide receiver
on the field tonight that's for sure he
is the best i'll say it right now he is
but the competition is not very good but
i'm gonna go with the field nonetheless
really because of a guy on his own team
like really the guy that jumped out to
me right away when i went i went well
man noah fans really good and he's been
a big part of that offense i could see a
guy like brett ripon who's yeah young
guy you know live over the middle big
target there he is i could see him
there's not a lot to read so i'll go
with the field uh
even though judy is clearly the best
receiver on the field tonight
yeah you know i'm gonna go i'll go with
the field as well there's too many in
the field and it's not like jerry judy's
jerry rice jerry rice i'll take jerry
rice yeah uh otherwise there's too many
other guys there's too many other
possibilities give me the field all
right
18 to 1 odds the jets going 0 and 16
this season plus 1800 is that a bet
you're gonna take um no it's not i mean
i just feel like it's so hard to go
winless even though i know the cleveland
browns have showed the ability to do
that quite well but
uh just
no i i would not take that i just think
at some point they'll they'll find the
right team to get one or two wins or
something like that um so no i would not
bet that you would
a hundred dollars you'd win eighteen
hundred i mean yeah if i just
weigh but yes okay well
look at the schedule though yeah um
it's scary
it's yeah there there aren't a lot of
weight off screaming out on that
schedule yeah um
they've got the dolphins twice in in
consecutive games with a buy in between
i i don't i don't know it's really
a coaching change in season
who knows i know it's scary you're right
there's not a team out there
they're not they're gonna be the
underdog in every game yeah you're gonna
be the underdog in every game they're
the underdogs tonight against the
broncos for crying out that's insane
that's insane but they're the worst team
in football and you're right i mean even
looking at the schedule that's scary
a little scarier than i thought and the
dolphins are
better than they are so um
they might maybe i need to rethink that
maybe i need to do that all right 100 uh
number one number one pick in the 2021
draft you're going trevor lawrence or
the field because all these winless
teams are jockeying for position
potentially to take lawrence he's minus
300 as the first overall pick in the
draft via points bet justin fields the
ohio state quarterback is next at plus
300.
lawrence or the field i'm going lawrence
i'm going lawrence i am i'm gonna go out
there and say it i mean
you know a year ago you would have said
tua
over the field um i don't think right
now a year ago right now i don't know if
i would have i liked justin herbert more
than him last year for sure i was always
a herbert guy burroughs the one that
jumped in the scene and crossed
everybody up a little bit but
uh the jets are at a spot here where
this is going to be very interesting
they go oh and 16. listen sam darnold's
not the problem we know that he's not
you can win football games with sam
darnold is sam darnold a special special
talent absolutely not we've already seen
in that draft in that draft class josh
allen and lamar jackson
are far more special than baker mayfield
or sam darnold that's for sure trevor
lawrence is one of these guys that is
going to make a team think wow we have a
decent starter but damn this could be
the next big thing i mean he can throw
it as hard and as far as he wants he's
big he's smart he's played in big
football games he's running for 60-yard
touchdowns against ohio state who's got
a secondary that's full of four three
guys um
i i i think that's a very real
possibility is what i'm saying i would
not be all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports